all right a Toyota dealer in California
is refusing to sell certain models of
the popular Toyota Prius over a
potential safety issue the automaker
began voluntarily we're calling hundreds
of thousands of Prius hybrids in 2014
and 2015 because some cars would lose
power while being driven now it affects
vehicles from model years 2010 to 2014
Toyota says it issued an effective
remedy but one dealership is suing
saying it doesn't fix the problem the
automaker says the lawsuit is not about
a safety problem it is instead about bad
blood Kris Van Cleave in Washington
shows us the escalating feud Chris good
morning good morning these voluntary
recalls dealt with a component known as
the inverter right here in the engine
now several years later car dealer Roger
Hogan says he sees a steady stream of
these hybrids coming into his
dealerships with an issue
he believes the recall should have fixed
the experience was terrifying
Kathleen Ryan says she was in the fast
lane on this busy Los Angeles freeway in
January when something went wrong in her
2010 Toyota Prius hybrid it felt like
someone pulled the emergency brake I
mean I couldn't believe what was
happening and he stepped on the
accelerator and nothing happened a
Toyota mechanic traced the problem to
the cars inverter which controls the
transfer of electricity between the
battery and the Prius is to electric
motors in 2014 Ryan's Prius was among
roughly 800,000 voluntarily recalled
because a circuit in the inverter could
overheat and fail potentially causing
the vehicle to lose propulsion repair
documents show she got the software fix
offered by Toyota that added a failsafe
mode intended to keep the car running at
a reduced speed long enough for a driver
to safely get off the road you won't
sell any of these cars these are these
are no sale these are locked up keys are
pulled in the computer do not sell these
cars
Roger Hogan owns to Southern California
Toyota dealerships he says after seeing
more than 100 of the sedans come in with
failed inverters that had previously
received the recall fix he stopped
selling many used Priuses which were
among his best sellers a recall is
supposed to prevent the incident from
happen
it's not supposed to be you fix it after
you've experienced the horrific event
you're supposed to prevent that event
from ever occurring why should you be
allowed to put someone's life in danger
do you feel like toda is putting
people's lives in danger
absolutely Hogan will still take Priuses
as trade-ins but if it's a 2010 to 2015
they're going to end up here on the roof
there are about 50 of them parked he
estimates having a million dollars
parked in Priuses he will not sell in
the 40 years you've been in the car
business how often have you unilaterally
done a stop sale on a type of car I've
never done anything like this I've never
felt I had the need to do anything like
this in October a Toyota vice president
wrote to Hogan when implemented the
software change lessens the likelihood
of a failure in once in failsafe mode
the vehicle can be safely driven for
some time but in December
Hogan petitioned federal regulators to
investigate the recall fix for not
addressing the inverter failures
directly writing there are lives
needlessly at risk something caused
these holes and if metal screws inside
this inverter Hogan showed us that it
melted and something pierced the
aluminum cover it came out of Martha
Anderson's 2012 Prius the engine
component got the recall repair prior to
failing late last year on this busy road
with a 50 mile an hour speed limit it
slowed down to the point that I was
barely going and fortunately there
wasn't a lot of traffic on there
thankful that I wasn't on the freeway if
you hit the gas did anything happen no
no it didn't
hogan is also suing Toyota for a hundred
million dollars his suit alleges breach
of contract and fraud arguing the
automakers remedy did not fix the safety
defect according to the complaint the
software fix costs about $80 a car to
replace the inverter can cost up to
three grand each the company changed the
inverter design in late 2014
Hogan suit also claims Toyota is trying
to block him from handing over his
dealerships to his sons but Toyota says
there is not a safety issue here and
Hogan's claims are without merit the
company has confidence its remedy is
effective and the recalls addition of a
failsafe mode was implemented to an
vehicle safety instead Toyota argues the
timing of the lawsuit and Hogan's claims
are motivated primarily by a separate
dispute he has with Toyota over
management and succession issues
involving his dealership
not the effectiveness of the Prius
inverter recall I say that's what juries
are for I don't want to be presumptuous
I don't want to prejudge the case I
don't want to argue my case in the media
I want to try it in court and I look
forward to it very much they're going to
be people who see this and say this is
about promoting a lawsuit that you have
a garage against Toyota that it's not
isn't really about the Prius my real
grudge was Toyota has always been there
lack of commitment to customer safety
that's what started this problem I
didn't create the hundred failures at my
two stores I didn't manufacture those
cars and then issue a recall that
doesn't work Toyota did Ryan is still
driving her Prius but now with a new
inverter I really appreciate the
opportunity to share this story because
people who have these priuses who have
had them recalled and assume that
everything is ok this could happen to
them the National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration tells CBS this morning
it is monitoring its complaints and will
take action as needed Toyota in cysts
that the vehicles are safe and says it
too is monitoring the issue
Gail all right thank you Chris